STEPHEN CARPENTER: What
I wanted to demonstrate
is how this press works.
I want to show how to make
a proper water filter.
And this is a
ceramic water filter
that I'm going to create here.
And that's essentially a
focus of the first talk.
This is bisque-fired filters
made with clay and sawdust.
Dry clay, dry
sawdust, about 50/50.
And when the sawdust burns
out, it leaves pores.
Now, the clay is
naturally porous,
but the sawdust allows
for more porosity,
and so the water
can flow through.
If you have water
that's contaminated
with microbes and pathogens
that might create things
like cholera, E.
coli, Giardia, you
can put that water
into this filter.
It will filter about one
to three liters an hour.
And that water is rendered about
95% free of those contaminants.
If we add a small amount of
colloidal silver to the filter
by brushing it on--
usually, it's a less than a
gram with about 500 milliliters
of water.
That silver acts as a
natural antimicrobial
and will render inert
approximately the remaining 4
and 1/2% to 5% of the bad
stuff that's in that water.
So this is one of
those approaches that
allows us to have potable
water or adequate access
to clean water.
A few years ago, I was working
with some undergrad engineering
students.
I said, look, I
have this dilemma.
Here's the situation.
We have this big press
that's used conventionally
to make these filters,
but it's really tough
to take with me on the road.
Can you make one that
fits in a suitcase?
They said, yeah.
Can you make one that makes
the same size filters?
Yeah.
Can you make one that
doesn't cost any money
or costs as little as possible?
They said, well, maybe.
And they did it.
This is the filter press.
It was collapsed earlier.
I assembled this.
And they made this out
of repurposed materials,
but also, some of
the material I gave
them, which was this bell, the
male and female molds here.
So I'll demonstrate how
this works to make a filter.
Usually, again, the filters
are made on a full-sized press,
but this is a smaller press.
This is both the prototype
and the final product
and the only one in existence.
Cool thing about this is
one person can operate it.
Usually with those big
presses, it's easier
if two people operate it.
But one person can do very well.
So this is a male mold.
This is essentially
very lightweight steel.
So we have this bell form.
And what we're going to do is
put the clay in the middle,
and we'll make the
filter this way.
So this is the metal mold,
the bottom of the mold.
I'm going to-- thank you--
put this plastic down
as a release agent.
Because the clay will
stick to the metal.
It doesn't like to
stick to the plastic.
And I have this bat.
It has a bevel in
it, approximately
the same angle as the bell.
Then, I'm going
to put this clay--
So I'm going to put the
second piece of plastic on,
and then I'll put this top part.
What's interesting is that the
original traditional approach
to these larger presses
used concrete molds,
and then they moved to
lighter weight metal molds.
And so this is the
same exact mold
that one would find
on a larger press.
Now, this is the part that
sometimes gets tricky,
because you've got to make
sure both of these sides
are latched down.
Take this arm and
tighten up the jack.
And then, with just a simple--
this is a fun part.
I like to say you have
to get up to get down.
You have to push this
thing up in order for it
to have resistance
and push back down.
At this point, I am going
to release the pressure.
All right, we'll
tighten this back up.
Certainly, this machine,
this press, portable press,
wouldn't necessarily work
well for a proper production
facility where you want to crank
out lots of filters in a day
or in a week.
But certainly, to
establish a facility
in a community that needs clean
water using this technology,
we can use this press to
create filters very quickly
and give ourselves a
baseline of not only
the clay but how the
filtration works.
Lift this back up.
Take the bell off.
And there's our filter.
Just takes a little bit
of cleanup at this point.
Again, I'm using my thumb just
to pull some of this extra off,
but I could certainly use--
and this is what you would
do in a production facility,
would be to take a clay tool
and to clean this up, as well.
And then, because this bat
is wider than the base,
I simply lift, and
there's the filter.
I can lay this--
place this down on a shelf in
the studio or in the facility.
Another worker
would clean it up,
smooth up some of
the edges, perhaps.
Stamp it with a
date and a number
so we can track the
way that it operates.
We let it dry, then we fire it.
We put it in the kiln.
We fire it to about 866
degrees C. And what happens
then is the sawdust
burns out, which
then creates a more porous
vessel that allows the water
to flow at a more
rapid pace than it
would if it wasn't as porous.
This is ready to
make another filter.
I could put plastic
down, another bat down.
We could continue to make
filters as long as we had clay.
So with one person, that was,
what, about a 10-minute time
frame.
With two people, you could
move much more quickly.
But the reason I wanted
to demonstrate this to you
is to show you, in
real time, what it
takes to create a water filter.
What if you designed houses,
what if you designed shelters,
what if you designed access
to water as if you really
cared about people getting it?
Not that you cared about
making money from it,
or that you were
interested in fame,
or that you were just
doing it to do it.
What if you gave a damn
about the situation?
What if you cared
in more direct ways?
What would that look like?
In ways that would be affordable
to people who need it,
but also appropriate in terms
of appropriate technology.
The idea that
materials and practices
and processes that
allow for things
like shelter and food and
water access to happen
do not complicate a cultural
set of rules and practices.
It's appropriate
for the culture.
for the situation.
Thinking about culture as the
way we do things around here.
So does the technology
interrupt the way
we do things around here?
Does it pose confusion?
So this is the gentleman
who invented, or is credited
with coming up
with, the approach,
Dr. Fernando Mazariegos,
who was from Guatemala.
And as a first response
to natural disasters,
Mazariegos thought if we
had this porous vessel that
allowed for water
to flow through,
that contaminated water to flow
through at a fairly rapid pace,
we might be able to produce
adequate access to clean water,
to potable water, after
natural disasters.
And so Mazariegos then was
contacted by Ron Rivera.
Ron was working with Potters
For Peace at the time.
This was in the late
'80s, early '90s.
And Ron learned the
process and started
setting up a water filter
production facility
through Potters For Peace.
Met Ron Rivera a number of
years ago at a conference.
And several months after
I met him, he passed away.
He was working in Nigeria to
help a community set up a water
filter production
facility so that they
wouldn't contract malaria and
would not die from malaria.
Ron came back from
that trip and died
from a very rare and
difficult strain of malaria.
So he gave his life so that
others could have clean water.
And whenever I give
a presentation,
I always think of that very
special moment meeting Ron.
But the idea is that it's
possible for this technology
to be passed along
to folks so that they
can use it to move
throughout the world
and through communities
to help other people.
This is a cross-section.
This is a drawing that
Manny did of the filter
inside the receptacle.
You see the addition
of a spigot and a lid.
And these are two
important components.
You need a spigot
to get the water out
and a lid to keep
hands and other things
entering into the filter.
Contamination is a
big issue, right?
These filters, as
you see here, if they
were sitting on a
counter in a kitchen,
you can put anything in.
Your hands can touch them.
External things
could touch them.
And you can
contaminate the water.
Even the water that is flowing
through can get contaminated.
So a lid is necessary.
I don't know if you
can hear, but this one
is dripping quite loudly now
that the water is flowing.
We have some dirty water
that we were using earlier.
And we filled these filters up.
I'm going to lift this
one up so you can see it.
You can't see the cross-section.
This is the cross-section.
Here's the spigot.
I don't have the lid,
but I'll lift this up.
You'll notice the
bell shape, and you
should see the water
dripping from the filter.
You see that?
And if you come up later,
after we give this little chat,
you'll be able to see the
clean water that's in there.
So this is a point-of-use
water filter.
It's placed in the
point in which it
will be used in the home,
usually in a kitchen.
And the idea is that you would
fill it up in the morning--
in the evening, I'm sorry,
before you go to sleep.
It will filter through the
night, and in the morning,
you have water for
cooking and drinking.
You fill it up again
sometime during the day,
and then you have another
batch of water in the evening.
So, again, point-of-use
water filters.
These filters, again, the
technology is the same.
The idea is the same, but
because clay and needs are
different in
different locations,
various organizations
have set up facilities
under different names, but
using the same technology,
the same idea.
Because the need for clean
water is a global need.
The right to access to water
is a basic human right.
So this little girl and the
other two children in the image
are drinking water
like they do every day.
I can go right to that water
fountain down the hallway
and get a drink of water, or my
water bottle is here somewhere.
I can drink out of that.
Many of you have water bottles.
This is the same water that
you see in the background.
This water is the same water
where the cows have defecated,
where people have thrown
away whatever it is they're
throwing away in that water.
This little girl is in Honduras.
This gentleman is getting
water for his family, his well.
And that box has a little
opening on the face,
on the plane facing us.
He reaches his hand in,
puts a few coins in there,
and the water comes
out of that long tube.
Water's been sitting in some
sort of receptacle reservoir
underneath.
He fills up the containers
in the back of his truck
and then drives those
containers home.
Then has to figure out how to
get the water into his house.
Then has to figure
out how to make sure
the water is clean
and safe to drink.
This gentleman is in South
Texas, outside of Laredo.
Half a million people do not
have utilities, paved roads,
and housing that's up
to code in South Texas,
from El Paso to Brownsville
and 150 miles north,
that green swath that
you see in that map.
That's South Texas.
Half a million people.
They don't have adequate
access to clean water, either.
And so my colleague at
Texas A&M, Oscar Munoz,
is the director of
the Colonias program
and works with communities
along that region.
Social practice and
public pedagogy,
linking those two, this notion
of intentionally disruptive
responsibility.
Social practice
being a term that
grows out of a number of
moves in contemporary art,
where it has been theorized
by people like Clara Bishop
and Pablo Helguera
and others to think
about the way in which
artists or artistic practices
intersect with social
issues and conventions
from other disciplines
to make positive change
or to enact change
through intentional modes.
Public pedagogy, very much
like what we did this morning.
We were out, essentially,
on the sidewalk--
or we were on the patio that
overlooked the sidewalk--
mixing clay and
sawdust in preparation
for making water filters.
And people stopped and
said, what are you doing?
Right there, you have
developed a relationship,
this interchange, by asking
a question and responding
and this back and forth
and back and forth.
There's some learning that
goes on in both directions.
And talking to folks
about the water filters
through a public forum
in a public space
is one form that we might
consider public pedagogy.
When I moved it to
Penn State, I decide
to put a name to these
performances-- collaborative
creative resistance.
I mean, Larry and I were
talking about titles.
And sometimes, the title's
enough to tease and pull folks
in.
But the idea of how
might we collaboratively
work together to resist
those hegemonic forces
or to disrupt what others
might find acceptable.
So with a small grant from
the Institute for the Arts
and Humanities, I
did a performance
in front of the
Palmer Museum of Art.
So there's a proximity
to the art museum.
So maybe it's more
art-like because it's
closer to the museum?
I'm not necessarily saying that.
But it was a
wonderful open space
that allowed for the middle
of campus to stumble upon it.
That was a Friday afternoon
in the middle of April.
Set up the press.
Started making filters.
People stopped by.
Students in art education and
in the School of Visual Arts
volunteered to sieve
sawdust and to mix the clay.
Although I knew this
would probably happen,
I didn't count on it happening
to the degree that it did.
In the background of this image,
and in the very foreground,
you probably see people
who are a little younger
than what you might expect
to see on college campuses.
These are children who came
from the local daycare center
on campus and from the
local elementary schools.
The daycare folks knew
I was going to do it,
because I had talked to them.
But the kids from the elementary
schools, their teachers
and the kids thought they
were going inside the museum
to see art.
But when they got off the bus,
they saw this guy with a fedora
wedging clay and using this
big guillotine-looking machine
in the middle of campus.
They'd rather stay outside
and talk to that guy.
We had wonderful conversations
about adequate access
to clean water.
Former student Sam
Bachmann, who's
a ceramic artist, dual degree
studio art and art education.
You can have class anywhere.
You can engage
education anywhere.
You can have learning anywhere.
Education is a relationship.
Teaching and learning
is a relationship
that's negotiated
between multiple parties.
And there's as much
learning going on
from whoever thinks they
might be the teacher as there
is from folks who
might initially
think they're the learner.
Everyone in that relationship
is learning and teaching
simultaneously.
[BIRDS CHIRPING]